[Music]
yeah yeah yeah opening logos blah blah
blah but can we talk about how in
addition to this
90 seconds of previously on and logoing
that we also end with
over four minutes of credits that's
almost six minutes of
not wanda visioning now i have to do
math every time i look at the run times
on d
plus and figure out if i actually do
have time to squeeze an episode in
before my friday colonic
and it's hard to work that out sometimes
[Music]
oh yes let's pretend that last night
wanda would expand the boundaries of her
hex to save vision but then not
actually go find him and ensure that
he's alive
[Music]
setting aside that uno isn't even a
video game it was only invented about
five years before the atari why not go
with pong controllers
that have been around in some form since
the 60s even if you don't do video games
go with a paddle ball or
marbles or regular old playing cards i'm
just saying when thinking about how many
choices you had here you certainly had
more than uno
mom my head feels weird it's like
really noisy i don't like it
resting her eyes
ignoring a clear sign that your child is
in need of supernatural medical
attention
i plan on taking a quarantine style
staycation sorry wanda you don't get to
call a pleasant break away from your
kids a quarantine
not in 2021 you don't you never even put
on a mask
sure jokes hearty heart but everyone
else's clothes have changed and even
your hair is different
i get that someone is producing all this
but we've also been led to believe that
the anomaly itself changes material
things to match the era automatically so
we should clearly be in pajama territory
here
aha cane cola more clues
this is obviously a reference to scrooge
mcduck who walks with a cane
come on disney these tie-ins are getting
to be a bit much on a completely
unrelated note i wonder if cane cola
comes in a six-pack
also where's the food there are two
shelves here dedicated to beverages
alone
where are the leftover containers and
yes i know vision doesn't eat but you
had your bushels of fruit in the 80s so
at least throw some lunchables in here
listen if you're going to use the box
for clever metaphors like
vision starting at the edge of town at a
circus and needing to get to the center
of town to his wife
or calling it sugar snaps in reference
to the infinity snaps
why not use all the box for cleverness
unless of course repeating these
nutrients four times in a row
is a clue which it isn't also where's
the riboflavin
a simple moment that is absolutely my
favorite from this episode with the milk
changing from milk from 1950 i would
have send it if you didn't give it the
quick smell test
but you did and i smiled dang it
elizabeth stop being so good at this
lying setting unrealistic beauty
standards my god who wakes up looking
this good
no one okay no one hidden mickeys
can i help you creeper you don't
remember me from last night
who's the real creeper here vision's
been passed out in the field all night
and all you
guys are just out here clowning around
what wii game is this
and how is this interface even a
two-player game also setting up your wii
without the censor bar in place
also also this is a terrible place for
your tv
who puts the tv in the middle of the
room with two chairs facing away from
the television
also times three this is some of the
worst cord management i've ever seen
apparently this is plugged into the
floor somehow and then you just threw
the mess of cords out in full view
find a wicker basket for that you cord
jumbling chaos monsters
vision is made of vibranium they
literally inherited tough skin
assuming to understand the complexity of
the genetics of your children when they
were born in a fake sitcom in a fantasy
universe
agnes is in full stride here meaning she
knocked on the door and took about six
steps back to strut on in
i'm a little impressed but mostly
annoyed
i'll be fine just go with agnes
parenting i mean my parents once left me
with a family of strangers in l.a so
they could attend a taping of the price
is right and
i'm still here and so very well adjusted
so fine i'm fine
i'm fine our conversations with
ourselves every day of the past pandemic
year somehow make it into the script
the most unbelievable thing in this
email from darcy is that in the rushed
moments to get this to them she took the
time to properly punctuate
each letter in the terrible sward
acronym i didn't even do this in this
subtitle and i had plenty of time it's
just that as any woman can attest to
having to deal with constant periods is
extremely annoying
did we get your specs right yes and
within one day
the well-known efficiency of
governmental agencies comes through
again
fool the guesser games yes please tell
me how old you think i am and how much
you think i weigh
can we go to the would you like to get
kicked in the balls or punched in the
booth next
please and who is that impostor pietro
vision is like the third person already
in this episode to plot jesus with this
question and we get it marvel another
big reveal is coming at this point
you're building it up so much i'd be
disappointed if pietro isn't revealed in
the final shot as hugh jackman flipping
the middle claw and dropping an f-bomb
at a local westview bar
you're not supposed to talk considering
we never once hear the interviewers in
modern family the sitcom this episode is
mostly based on
i think one has a point here and
therefore would be excellent at tv
sins a unique antidepressant that works
to anchor you back to your reality
or the reality of your choice get it
multiple realities
you could even call them virtual
realities it's clear now with this in
the video games earlier that wand is
going to create
nexus which as we all know will be the
name of a virtual reality headset where
she and super horny vision can have lots
of sex
guys i'm getting super good at picking
up on these easter eggs she's gonna sail
right through
unharmed obvious overconfident premature
celebration is premature
and obvious i can get through and i
won't be needing this anymore
so wanda killed me a full minute
rehashing a moment we
already saw in the movie being
referenced i didn't realize the infinity
in infinity war referred to how long
marvel would continue to refer back to
it in its properties
take a lesson from your own show marvel
move on already oh
and another red light uh overkill out in
the sticks here don't you think
overkill a maybe a little insensitive to
the guy who just learned he was killed
twice
superhero is an obvious superhero
because they know how to land in a
superhero pose cliche
oh you do is lie but wouldn't want to be
slightly interested in how monica is
showing up in sward gear that hadn't
been altered on its way through the hex
which reminds me why weren't her clothes
transported like everything else coming
through
monica herself is a superhuman now but
are her clothes
what am i doing here sitting talking to
you
great question and honestly this has
been building for a while but how does
the timing of any of this make any sense
most of this stuff has been shown to be
really happening so when was this
recorded and why does it take place in
sequence with him flying out of the
truck what is happening when and why and
how and where and when does deathstroke
finally show up
[Music]
nice this show is super fun and
catherine hahn is a treasure and i'm
so glad she's getting to shine here
there are plenty of reasons i could
remove another sin for one division but
this one is for han
solo we did
everyone did and i killed sparky too
bragging about dog murder
this screen not only does it taunt me
every week it's taken me until this
episode to finally realize it's not
saying there will be a mid-credits scene
so this week i'll finally turn off the
show and not stick around hoping for a
scene that never shows up can you
imagine if they waited till the seventh
episode to do any kind of mid-credits
scene good thing that would never happen
your aura is purple three pillow pennies
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
commercials
[Music]
tired
[Music]
actually did bite a kid once i know the
babies taste best
i see dead people there's no earthly way
of knowing
which direction we are going
[Music]
bring back the balance ray as i did in
the night
and i killed your little dog